agora parece que está maior mas não é
câmera que tem muito pra escola tudo
soava aqui quem fala é o dar que sejam
muito bem vindos em mais um vídeo
mostrado g500 melhor o susto e no
momento não os melhores sustos e fiações
3 antes de começarem a ver o vídeo eu
gostava de saber a vossa opinião sobre
esta câmera e comprei esta câmera ontem
com a intenção de começar a fazer pode
sair com ela e tal médio também tem
muita qualidade dela aqui dentro ficou
outro guarda espaço com esta quebra você
consegue também enfermagem e ações de
conseguir o meu corpinho não só obeso
dilma e nos comentários a vossa opinião
querem continuar a viver esta câmera tem
mais cuidado ao menos gosta mais da
outras gostam mas desta não sair de uma
voz opinião pois é isso pessoal fica
então com vídeo dos melhores surgir e
ações já sabem como tem isso aí que
vocês acham sobre esta quebra é é isso
que conviviam fiquem mais se aproximam
eu não conseguia levar muito mas não
interessa quadros mais visados colo como
ele não vai propor também não fui para a
porta não a vamos lá
ae o que é isto mesmo né não tá meu bem
é ei não é por aí que eu acho que não
era para eu não cair
temos que salvar a criança não percebo
vai mudar uma porca abrigo foi esta
porta vamos embora
não vamos embora que a casa é perigoso
a citgo isto é muito intenso a minha
perna não aguenta isso nem minha cueca
nenhuma operação nenhum cérebros nada
quer aqui roubar seu sangue aqui e agora
o jogo é a galera que pagaram anda aqui
está entre os piores não armário quem
fecha a porta eu não sei se já subi as
escadas não não não
aqui à luz porque a gente segurança
acontece nada és tu é que isso ela conta
pouco o que é aquilo que você contrata
uma empregada por mim para o sonho foi
bem
sabes chove
olha o dele
agora é fácil apanhar aqui mesmo estão
na casa do meu looks
isto é uma foto em casa
então qualquer coisa qualquer coisa boa
pode escutar que da equipe gaúcha não
dar fim a uma novela e agora sim nós
vamos encaixar a esta hora não travou a
igrja tudo escuro porque quando se joga
outra vez porque muitos dos jogos art
cada vez que vejo uma porta eu tenho que
ver aquela que era aquilo era uma luva
napster que era preciso para a câmera
o bolo eu encosto uma pedra no lucro eu
estava maluco então os 249 inépcia ou
faltando duas horas para conseguir
passar esta noite dois autocarros
alteração e se jogou em um fox e um fax
nada eu sei que ela possa agora está
aberta a porta não não
agora não agora sem o mesmo olho na casa
da irmã que eu vou fazer a minha vida
precisa captar mais rápido do mundo
outra vez meu como é que é possível o
bulls em luziânia tão rápido
estava vivo está bom é realista parece
mesmo que a mulher tá aqui não toques
conheceram nojenta e ficar atenta cama
então não sei o que quis ferir quem
torce foxy oitavo game e se não faltar
alguém mexer nela é talea alguém mais
velho ajuda ai ai ta de qualquer coisa
no chão já que eu moro no chão tudo
muito o maior foco não está lendo isso
vai pra mim eu deus com bonecos ou não
não é isso aí tanto ou mais gols parece
tudo bem vamos fechar não dá não dá no
bairro à porta o macaco este tua mãe eu
quiser